parce que c'est un fait heureux
aujourd'hui sa fille alice bâle et coire
d'un buste
c'est superbe pour moi qu'est ce que
c'est maman c'est pas mal
et pourquoi cet engouement ironie du
sort la maman justement d'oeil à jacques
et les deux fusées genre pour quatre ans
je fais quand je marche à croquer merci
madame en face à six-fours temps de
s'occuper celle d'une petite fille de 5
ans les repas la toilette et le
rangement jacques fort bien que mal de
s'en nourrissent les inculpés jusqu'à
l'heure je termine mon travail je le
récupère en général vers 19h 19h30 et
sortent quand même récupérer les
allemands gel douche est pendante une
voie d'en face c'est uniquement pour
jouer mais c'est surtout le dimanche que
jacques profit des plafonds aujourd'hui
après le repas de la fête des pères
il est diffusé dès le premier